you know I can actually see how Vince
Vaughn's pitch for this movie happened
because he did the story and half the
screenplay for this movie is probably
like this hey guys look so I want to
make a movie about Google well get
Google in every shot well say Google and
every scene will pay for every single
thing in the movie going to have a
production budget we can just do it all
ourselves Google will pay for all our
money because I have to do it say hey we
want to move you all about you and make
you guys look great what make your
industry look great we want to make
everything about you look great
so you can make us look great by giving
us a lot of money and we'll do
everything ourselves right big product
placement movie just Google and every
single shot how about that is that cool
is that cool with you guys oh maybe I
could only listen to because he's my
buddy the internship is directed by
Shawn Levy and stars Vince Vaughn Owen
Wilson and Rose Byrne this movie is
about two guys they're salesmen and
Vince Vaughn comes up with this idea hey
let's try to be interns at Google and
try to get a job there because they're
having this big competition for interns
right now and whoever wins this
competition gets a job at Google so then
they go off to California they're at
Google industries and they have this
giant face-off against these other teams
of interns and these tech-savvy kids
that are now on their team have to teach
Owen Wilson and Vince Vaughn about code
and the internet and Google and
everything and Vaughn and Wilson had to
teach these kids how to be a team and
how to be people persons and how to be
likeable and how to talk to other people
and sell themselves basically
so they come together and be a team and
hijinx and heartwarming scenes into when
I look at the plot synopsis for this
movie I see a possibility for a really
great comedy in there unfortunately the
filmmakers and the writers decide to
take it in the most cliched way they
possibly could Vince Vaughn and Owen
Wilson both play two really likeable
characters I enjoyed their characters in
this movie they were funny at times and
they weren't annoying as I was afraid
they were going to be Vince Vaughn can
sometimes be annoying in his comedies
because he continuously does this
fast-talking thing I'm the talker on the
talker but that kind of worked for his
character since he plays a Salesman for
once they actually gave him a role that
seemed to fit his style and Owen Wilson
is likable you can't really look at Owen
Wilson and hate the guy you can kind of
see how the meeting came together before
they made this movie Vince Vaughn was
talking to Owen Wilson it went something
like this
hey men do want to be in a comedy with
me yeah it's about Google they're gonna
pay for like every single thing in this
movie because they're gonna be Google it
every single shot we're gonna say Google
and every single scene and it's all
gonna be about Google Google and it's
gonna be a lot of fun who could be like
these interns gonna be a lot of fun what
do you think yeah man I don't really
have anything
going on right now because Zoolander 2
isn't really working out so these two
likable guys come together and they're
fun and enjoyable to watch and you don't
hate them
unfortunately the structure behind this
movie fits the bill of the most cliched
comedy structure you could think of
there's of course the big evil bully in
turn who really wants the job for
himself who comes in and out of every
scene with a giant Posse following him
of hot people and this guy isn't cool
you're not supposed to like this guy
he's the guy from social network which
is funny because in social network he
also played a guy who was competing for
a bit of Internet glory which is funny
to me that he would do the same thing in
the internship mmm Titan cast he got
Rose Byrne playing the cute girl that
already works for Google and Owen
Wilson's starting to lust after her and
they start a thing together you got the
big heartwarming scene where everyone
becomes a family and everyone wants to
work together and everything and I'm not
going to spoil what happens in the last
30 minutes but every single thing you
could possibly think of that would
happen in a movie like this does happen
within the last 30 minutes of the movie
it's not a horrible movie it's a
perfectly watchable movie it just has no
surprises at all the best way that I can
describe the internship is to say like
let's say you were having a family
barbecue and you had a whole bunch of
people over and you guys were going to
have food and you're going to have
drinks the internship would be like the
perfect movie to have on the television
in the background no one's really paying
attention to it if anyone stops and
looks at it they'd be like oh that's a
pleasant movie yeah those are two nice
guys alright back to my hot dog it would
set a nice heartwarming tone for your
party anyone who paid attention to it
for like two seconds you'd be like oh
that's a nice little movie okay alright
but anyone will actually sat down and
watched it would be like wow this is a
pretty cliched movie it's you know it is
what it is but no one would be doing
that because it'd all be enjoying your
barbeque see it's the perfect barbecue
movie to just have on in the background
I guess that's kind of a really bad
insult your movies perfect to just kind
of have on there not really pay
attention to like I said it's a
watchable movie with two likable leads
but it's the most cliched story
structure you have available and it's
not really funny but it has some fun
moments to it as well but it's just so
easy to predict where each scene is
going so I'm going to give the
internship a C+
as always guys thanks for watching and
if you like this you can click right
here and get stuck menage
[Music]